[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein besonderer tag für die
luftstreitkräfte die blackrock staffel
den langen leben am fliegerhorst
borowski erhält am 15 märz den ersten
modernisierten blackrock mit dem neuen
bionik update der leiter der luft zeigt
abteilung brigadier freistädter übergibt
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
das bordbuch bevor es an staffel
kommandant major sieger geht für ihn ist
der blackrock mit neuen bionik system
ein großer sprung nach vorne
ja mittlerweile betreiben wir diesen
hubschrauber seit annähernd 20 jahren
es war zum ersten mal dass wir in
österreich einen militärhubschrauber
bekamen der mit computern und
bildschirmen ausgestattet wurde und nach
einigen jahren nach zehn 15 jahren ist
es einfach notwendig diese bildschirme
auszutauschen das war eigentlich die die
grundidee warum ein neues update 1
avionik update in dem hubschrauber
notwendig geworden ist
es wurden zwei große systeme eingebaut
erstens ein gaming system wo wiederum
ein glas cockpit hergestellt wurde mit
vier bildschirmen
man spricht jeweils von einem primaries
leid display mit mit dem der pilot
fliegt und ein zweites einmal gefangen
display an dem die karten eingeblendet
werden können in den verschiedensten
variationen das zweite system ist ein
airbag system ein missionsland system es
handelt sich ja immer noch um einen
militärhubschrauber und dort können
anhand eines laptops computer in der
staffel die aufträge die missionen
geplant werden das wird auf
speicherkarten auf sd cards wird das
gespeichert und dann kann man das im
hubschrauber in das missionsdesign
spielen und zur anzeige bringen
diese wichtigen umrüstungen sollen den
flugdienst um einiges erleichtern
doch wie schlägt sich der modernisierte
black in wahrheit schlägt sich so wie
vorher weil der hubschrauber ist ja der
gleiche die instrumentierung natürlich
ist sehr beeindruckend weil es was die
luftfahrt betrifft state-of-the-art
diesem jahrtausend entspricht also es
ist schon sehr beeindruckend
man hat einen guten überblick das war
auch dass die konzeption dieses cockpit
die sogenannte situational awareness
dass die informationen die der pilot
braucht um immer zu wissen immer sicher
unterwegs zu sein dass das entsprechend
aufbereitet wird ja flüchtig was das
cockpit betrifft anders und sehr gut und
sehr beeindruckt auch
verteidigungsministerin tag zeigt sich
erfreut über die neuen cockpits und
bekommt eine persönliche einweisung
durch den staffel kommandanten dieser
blackrock ist der erste fertiggestellte
hubschrauber der nunmehr über ein
nagelneues cockpit verfügt dass ich auch
auf dem aktuellsten stand der technik
befindet für die restlichen acht
blackhawks folgt das selbe update aber
nicht nur das die black familie bekommt
zuwachs
neben der modernisierung unserer neuen
black hawk haben wir auch drei weitere
black hawk in diesem programm geschafft
damit am ende die einsatzstoffe 20 jahre
nach zulauf des ersten black hawk
endlich voll aufgefüllt sein wird diese
drei zusätzliche hubschrauber werden
ebenso mit diesen neuen kopf wird
ausgestattet um nach lieferung durch die
firma erotik sind der einsatzstoffe
verwendet werden die black hawks werden
im österreichischen bundesheer
hauptsächlich versicherungs und
rettungseinsätze sowie bei assistenz
einsätzen für material und
gütertransporte verwendet
es wurden auch bereits cupid patienten
mit einem sogenannten medevac system
isoliert transportiert ohne die
besatzung einem infektionsrisiko
auszusetzen
die hubschrauber können bei nahezu jeder
witterung bei tag und bei nacht im in-
und im ausland eingesetzt werden
[Musik]